a man accused of driving under the
influence and killing two pedestrians in
North Las Vegas on New Year's Day
appeared before judge today that
incident happened Sunday afternoon at
the intersection of Aliante Parkway and
Nature Park Drive by the 215. Joshua
peguero joining us now live and Joshua
you spoke directly to the family of one
of the victims
your Tracy sunburn is devastating she
and 68 year old Randall Ray were out
enjoying a New Year's Day walk when they
were struck waiting right here to cross
the street as you can see this is one of
several Memorial set up in the area you
have flowers notes and candles
the crash also left residence in the
neighborhood hoping for change
I'm very protective of my children
especially when we cross I try to
instill on them checking both ways and
just because you look doesn't mean the
driver's looking for you Michael
Harriman has lived in this neighborhood
for 10 years he sees cars speeding all
the time on Aliante Parkway people I
don't think concerned about the guy next
door they're not concerned about the
person next to him that may hold true of
what happened on New Year's Day police
say 21-year-old Fernando Reyes backed
into a car on the Aliante in 215
overpass when the driver asked him for
his insurance he took off speeding South
on Aliante when he ran a red light at
Nature Park Drive hitting another car
that was making a turn
that forced race onto the sidewalk where
he struck Tracy Sundberg and Randall Ray
in court prosecutors say he was under
the influence of Xanax
Reyes tried leaving the scene of that
crash too but a Good Samaritan tackled
him to the ground and others helped hold
them down until police arrived police
say he showed no remorse for what
happened as for the residents who live
in this area they believe more should be
done to clamp down on reckless driving
more they see the police I think that's
when he really people start to slow down
and get more cautious because then they
have the fear of actually being ticketed
or some sort of a penalty
in a statement Tracy sonnenberg's family
tells me they're devastated by the
senseless murder of her and Randall Ray
they say Tracy was a hospice nurse who
devoted her life to helping others
including her two daughters and Randy
was looking forward to retirement
reporting live from Aliante and Nature
Park Joshua peguero eight news now
Joshua thank you and sunberg's family
also say they really appreciate the
bystanders who helped at the scene
including those who prevented Reyes from
trying to leave